-Our next guest is an Emmy
and Tony award-winning
actress you know from shows
such as "Weeds,"
"The West Wing,"
and "Angels in America."
She is starring in
"How I learned to drive,"
which is playing at the
Manhattan theatre club's
Samuel J. Friedman Theatre.
Please welcome to the show
Mary-Louise Parker, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-I'm great.
-I'm so happy you're here,
especially --.
-Hi, Syd.
-Yeah, alright, you know
our bassist, Syd,
very well, right?
-Yeah, his daughter
is a rock star.
She's amazing.
-Yeah.
-And son, too, but Lyla,
I know better.
-Alright, well, I hope
Lyla's happy with this, Syd.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, so, this is really cool
that you're coming tonight,
because you obviously have a
show this evening on Broadway.
-I do.
-Does this interrupt
your pre-show warm-up?
-It does.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This will be my warm-up.
No, I just have a really long
warm-up and, um...
-Have you always had
that for any show?
Okay.
-I have, yeah,
and I'm really superstitious
about it.
And I'm superstitious
about my superstition about it.
-Right, you don't want to talk
about it too much.
but what time --
-I mean, there's no,
like, animals.
There's no, like, blood.
-Okay.
-Nothing like that,
but it'd just probably
be boring if you saw it.
-Yeah.
-I don't think anybody did think
it was blood until you said it.
And then it seemed
like a weird thing
you were maybe covering for.
-I promise there's no blood.
[ Laughter ]
-We were talking about actors
with Andrew, and you know,
the ability to give back
to younger actors.
You ran a drama camp?
-I did.
Well, it started as just
inviting my kids' friends,
you know, to the country,
to I thought,
well, we'll do plays
and we'll have pie fights
and do some yoga.
And then they invited
their friends,
who invited other friends,
and then it ended up being like,
you know, 18, 20 kids and we put
on a big show at the end.
It was incredible.
-And did they all show up
and appreciate what they were
going to have to put into it
to get something out of it?
-No.
No, they did.
Actually, they were incredible.
And I loved them all,
and I see them all.
Like, to this day, three of them
were at my house
for game night the other night.
-So you stay in touch
with your drama students?
-Yeah.
You want to come to my camp,
is what I'm feeling right now.
-I would love -- I feel like --
because I'm a bad actor,
and I feel like I missed
some early learning.
-But I bet you're
an ideal camper.
-Oh, I'm a really good camper.
-Yeah, I can see that.
-As long as you have
super nice bunks.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, bunks are okay,
lots of candy.
-Seth: That's good.
This sounds like a win.
Is your son, do you feel like he
is trending towards acting?
-He is --
I will say he is the best
natural actor I've ever seen.
-That's very high praise.
-And my daughter is the best
natural musician.
I feel like she
just has it in her.
She picks up any instrument,
and it never makes a bad sound.
-Can I ask, how early did you
know that with her?
-Well, when she said, you know,
"I'm gonna be playing flute,"
and I thought, you know,
she'd come home
and there would be bad sounds.
It never, ever sounded bad.
-How old was flute?
When did flute start?
-Flute started,
I think she was nine?
-Okay, gotcha.
-Now she plays harp.
She plays piano and ukulele.
-And it's all nice?
-Yeah, all of it.
-That's really great.
-She taught herself.
It's unbelievable.
And my son is a magician.
-Oh, wow.
-And he's a filmmaker,
but there's a lot --
the magician, I know.
-Is he good at magic?
-Well, he made his film
by the money --
he paid for it himself
from the money
he made doing magic lessons.
-Wow!
So, yeah, he wanted it to be
paid all his money.
-So, he taught magic to other
people at a level good enough
that he financed a film?
-But having a magician for a kid
is like, you know,
every morning you wake up to,
"Mommy, pick a card."
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "Honey, I'm asleep."
Literally for years,
or there'd be on the couch,
"What's this bloody thumb?
Why is this here?"
Like, just things
all over the house.
-Where you might --
-Or he comes out
coated in blood.
-Does he really?
-No, honest to God.
-Like, that seems
like a very scary trick.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, well, I also know all the
best places to buy fake blood.
This is turning into such
a bizarre...interview
[ Laughter ]
-Now I'm really starting to
think that you
kill an animal
in your warm-up.
-Alcone in Times Square, you can
get all different colors.
-Okay, is this a hashtag ad
situation?
Do you work
with the blood people?
-What is that?
-Okay, gotcha.
-I don't know.
-This Broadway show
is a show you did 25 years ago.
-By the amazing,
phenomenal Paula Vogel.
The play is really special.
-And your co-star David Morse
was also your co-star
25 years ago.
-And Johanna Day,
who's extraordinary.
And David Morse is really...
He's just some other
level of actor,
and if you can come
see the play, I mean,
aspects of it are quite heavy.
It's about --
I guess it's about --
Paula says it's about the gifts
from people who hurt us
and how, you know,
learning to forgive yourself
because sometimes
we blame ourselves
when other people have hurt us.
And it's learning to, uh,
let go of that.
-Well, that's a very
nice message.
So 25 years later, you still --
is it true that you
still don't know how to drive?
-No, I'm the worst driver alive.
And I think your producer
fixed my performance,
because not only is it about
driving but I have to mime.
I'm a horrible mime.
I'm driving because, you know,
when you mime,
like, as a steering wheel,
miming,
then you start talking
and then it becomes
like a Barbie steering wheel.
It's hard to keep
a consistent feel.
Your producer was -- I said,
I was a bad driver
and a bad mime, and she said,
"Well, you know,
it's funny because
when I was at the show
the other day," she said, "You
put the key in the ignition."
She said, "I think you turned it
towards you."
And I was on the phone with her,
and I was like,
"Oh, yeah, 'cause that's --
no, 'cause you turn it
this way to turn on a car."
So, last night, I went,
and I was like, "Yay, Sarah,"
because I --
nobody else noticed.
Maybe they were too afraid
to tell me.
-Was that the first time
since the run of the show?
-No, because, one time,
I get in the car,
I lock the door, I turn the key,
and I didn't even notice
that I done it.
When you smile, sometimes people
go, "No," and no one catches it.
-Well, you know what?
The hope, I think,
for all of us
is that when you do the show
a third time,
25 years from now,
you get the mime stuff down.
-Yeah.
-There are really good
mime camps out there.
-Well, I won't be able to.
Then I'll be on a walker.
I won't even have
a steering wheel.
-[ Laughs ] You're going to mime
a Barbie walker?
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-It's a delight talking to you.
Mary-Louise Parker, everybody!
"How I Learned to Drive,"
now playing
at the Samuel J. Friedman
Theatre.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."